D Ma Ri Ma Mari
If you believe that children try to understand the physics of the time involved in this,
then here you can see, first of all,
how the rope
is moving under a spring motion and also
Also, if you analyze the motion of that girl here,
an oscillating motion is happening
and look here, there are so many stones placed on the head of that girl
which
is in a perfect stable equilibrium and one more
interesting thing to notice here.  You will see that
the girl has a stick in her hand and
how well she is using that stick to
maintain her equilibrium.
This was a very amazing act and
perhaps it shows us that it is important to
understand physics.  For this, we should feel it and the
day we feel physics, perhaps
we will start understanding physics a lot.